flags every nation has one summer
rectangles summer squares and some honor
pools some like in Scandinavia have
common symbols like crosses and some
like Nations in Europe have similar
colors except for Lithuania who
apparently didn't get the memo yet one
color you won't see very often on any of
the flags in the world is purple and in
fact only two modern flags have the
color in them which raises the obvious
question why why a purple flag so rare
as many of you will know the color
purple was the color of royalty and was
historically associated with Roman
emperors the reason for this was that
purple dye was to put it mildly very
very expensive
there was one dye in particular Tyrion
died which was especially coveted due to
its deep color so flanks have been
around for a very long time in their use
as battle standards can be traced back
thousands of years to India China in the
Roman Empire however it was during the
medieval period in Europe that banners
Saints flags and royal standard slowly
took root is becoming an easily
identifiable symbol of nations this one
isn't a joke by the way the French royal
coat of arms was just a field of white
I'm not being mean anyway since Europe
is where Flags morphed international
symbols will focus on their you would
expect that Kings given their constantly
to one-up each other would have picked
purple for their colors but again I need
to stress this it was extremely
expensive so with one exception none of
the older European states have ever made
use of purple as a national color
because their need have less money to
spend on wars one group that make great
use of the color purple was the papacy
Cardinals wore purple robes
now Europeans had been trying to make
their own purple dye for centuries by
simply dyeing red cloth blue but the
results were mixed the best they could
do was this purple which was then
promptly adopted by the kingdom of
Castile in Leon for their flag as time
went on Europe's kingdoms became Nations
and the national symbols became
entrenched most of these nations then
became empires and so their own limited
range of flags dominated most of the
world's heraldry until the 19th century
but what about when these empires
collapsed what about the new nations
formed from them well for the nations
which broke away from the Spanish Empire
or say the United States of America
purple was still extremely expensive at
this point in fact it wasn't until the
1850s that a synthetic purple dye was
created and thus early nations created
after that would likely have a purple
flag now it's important to remember that
purple is used by the papacy and royalty
colored people's opinions of it when you
look at the nations which broke away
from the world's imperial powers most of
them were Republic's and many
them weren't Catholic and so for them
purple was tainted however there was one
notable exception in history Spain who
after the overthrow of its monarchy in
1931 adopted this amazing franc which
you will notice big ol purple stripe now
in Spain red and yellow were associated
with the kingdom of Aragon and purple
with Castile in Leon which is why it was
added to the flag and after the Spanish
Republic was Frank code its flag
returned to this and purple due to its
lack of history and flags in its
association with the Catholic Church and
monarchies never took hold as a major
color for flags I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
the special thanks to my patreon
supporters James Bissonnette calling
Castleman Danny Maloney Marvin Castle
Rob Waterhouse John BJ's Mo Aaron the
white Michael Reynolds James Castaneda
Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma Jordan Longley
James Castaneda Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma
Jordan long way Gareth Turner mr. show
Rashid Ali spinning three plates filled
- oink oink David Silverman Izzy
Winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski Lexi
Schwinn Spencer Lightfoot Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and Anthony
Beckett